Joe Biden inherited the most secure
Border in American history but since his
very first day in office Biden has done
everything to dismantle Trump error
policies the ones that worked that kept
the Border safe and secure but only now
with reelection looming all of a sudden
the same Joe Biden that's been lying to
us as everybody in the Administration
has been lying to us telling us The
Border's closed The Border's secure now
he's claiming he wants to do something
about the problem he himself created and
a bipartisan group of senators has been
working on a so-called deal to trade
enhanced border security for more Aid to
Ukraine and while we don't know all the
details because they haven't put it in
writing yet we do know that Biden
falsely claims that the bill would
enable him to shut down the Border one
problem sources telling Fox News that
provision would only kick in one several
thousand people cross each and every day
which as Speaker Mike Johnson rightly
points out is ridiculous outrageous a
nonstarter this bill is DOA in the house
former president Donald Trump has also
weighed and he's telling Republican
Senators not to give in and support a
weak bill that will allow the surge of
illegals to continue look at your screen
here are all the Trump policies that Joe
Biden reversed he can fix all of this he
did this all with the stroke of a pen he
can undo them with the stroke of a pen
congressional action is not required
just bring back the Trump policies that
worked and things at the border are only
getting worse and worse our very own
Sarah Carter she was in Eagle Pass today
speaking with the Texas Department of
Public Safety let's get an update take a
look because of what we've been able to
do as a state uh National Guard DPS we
have secured this area here in Shelby
Park Eagle Pass which has been known for
years that this is the place to cross if
you look at all the physical barriers
that National Guard put up this is a
deterrent this is what we need this goes
back to show you that walls do actually
work physical barriers actually work
we've never been in a situation like
this not only were we're having to
defend our state and our border but now
also you know this conflict this this
alleged conflict between us and federal
agents which is not even there but again
it all goes back to show you what the
priorities are for this federal
government their priorities are to allow
as many people into the country as
possible and also to create this
narrative uh or this conflict between us
and law enforcement federal law
enforcement which is not the case and I
think right there really shows you where
their priorities are and really what
they should be focusing on is securing
the Border they have the authority to do
that uh but they refuse to do that right
now all right Sarah Carter is live from
the border in Eagle Pass Texas along
with former senior adviser to president
Trump Steven Miller's with us Sarah
let's be very clear here the media mob
is lying as usual and the Democrats are
lying as usual and Joe Biden is lying as
per usual first of all the very people
that have been telling us the border
secure and closed uh now at least
recognize a problem uh however they are
lying and saying that they need
legislation to fix the problem no as
I've been scrolling Joe Biden's uh
resending of trump era policies that
worked contributed to all of it and his
aiding and abetting illegal immigrants
that just added to the problem him
telling them to come which he also did
also contributed to the problem so all
of this is on him why why is the media
buying this lie why are they
perpetrating this
lie well the media can perpetrate and
buy this lie all they want Sean but the
American people aren't buying it because
they see it every single day not only
here at the border where you can see the
concertina wire right behind me Governor
Greg Abbot has reinforced it um today in
fact even the National Guard was out
continuing to put up reinforcements the
Texas National Guard but the American
people can see what's happening because
they see the illegal migrants being
shipped off into housing facilities in
Chicago in airports like in Boston in
New York where we've been Sean where we
showed you right over at Floyd Bennett
Field where over 2,000 migrants are
being housed and they can see the
extreme nature of this situation where
right here even in Eagle Pass they've
had people coming from these are called
special interest aliens people from IRA
irq people from Syria people from
Pakistan that haven't been properly
vetted and from all over the world yeah
it's absolutely insane and I got let me
ask you this what is so incredible is
our yes go ahead finish finish your
thought what's so incredible no what I
what I want to make clear is that what's
so incredible is that our border patrol
our National Guard our Texas DPS even on
the very local level here in the county
uh the police officers that are working
here in Texas they are working together
and they know that this is working that
is the reason why you're not seeing
anybody coming over here and trying to
cut this concertina wire I mean it's not
going to happen unless like what you
said to Governor Greg Abbott unless for
some reason President Biden decides to
federalize uh you know the National
Guard and tries to force them to do that
and really that will Corner president B
him and and it will well first I got to
give a lot of props out to the to the
border patrol agents that are saying no
we support the Texas National Guard
we're grateful for their help and
assistance and their hard work got to
give them credit I don't think I don't
think Joe's going to be successful
federalizing the Texas National Guard
just my gut feeling and he's he's he's
literally pitting La law enforcement
against law enforcement very dangerous
however they're not they're not allowing
themselves to be put in the middle here
good for them on both sides um Steve
Miller what's your take on all of
this
well Sean I think you've done a
tremendous public service tonight by
listing all of the actions that Joe
Biden terminated that President Trump
used to achieve the most secure Border
in American history president Trump
ultimately implemented over
1,000 executive actions to secure the
border and to secure this nation's
immigration system many of many people
know the most famous ones remain in
Mexico safe thirds border wall title 42
border prosecutions immediate expulsion
from the Country Rapid deportations
ending Catch and Release to Tain through
removal Joe Biden came into office and
willfully terminated every single one of
these policies and he and mayorcas
violated the command in federal law and
the Very act that created Homeland
Security to guard this nation's borders
and to deter and prevent unlawful
entries into this country they are
criminals Joe Biden is a criminal
mayorcas is a criminal breaking federal
law every single day and they can secure
this border with a on sentence EO that
says restore all Trump policies
effective immediately the job that
speaker Johnson has is how can you force
Joe Biden to do involuntarily that that
he that which he refuses to do but has
the authority to do voluntarily that's
why the house passed a real border
security bill called hr2 the US Senate
Republican all they need to do is agree
with that part they don't need to be
negotiating with Biden and Chuck Schumer
the first of all the house isn't going
to go along with it so you know I I
think they're wasting people's time
Sarah we'll give you the last thought
here well you're absolutely right Sean I
mean look that bill is going to allow at
least 5,000 people to come into this
country illegally that's what they say
we know it's going to be a lot more than
that and that's day by day and you know
it was Jay Johnson under Barack Obama
that said when 1,000 a day were coming
over it was a crisis so imagine that
this is Biden's problem he's cornered
himself and now he's going to pay the
price for it unbelievable Beyond
dangerous for this country and I am
Telling You Terror cells are here of the
of the nearly 10 million unvetted when
you look at the countries they're coming
from one day he will have blood on his
hands and I pray to God that I am wrong
no doubt Sean I don't think I am sadly
that's a clear and present danger these
FBI guys were right hi everyone I'm
Brian killme I want you to do me a favor
I want you to click to subscribe to the
Fox News YouTube page this is the only
way that I know for sure that you're not
going to miss any great commentary any
great news bites any great interviews
coming your way on Fox you can get it
all here on YouTube so subscribe right
now